California governor Gavin nsome might be
an unctuous power hungry psychopath I'm
Michael NS no I'm just joking he he
might be all of those things but in his
defense he's sometimes honest about it
folks say oh they're just cleaning up
this place cuz all those fancy leaders
are coming into town um that's
true because it's
true but it's also true for months and
months and months prior to Apec we've
been having different
conversations people say we only stopped
the druggies from killing themselves and
the criminals from killing other people
because xiin ping is coming to town and
that's
true and in case San Francisco residents
did not get the point that impressing
foreigners is much more important than
their own lives according to these
politicians Gavin Nome made it even
clearer anytime you put on an event by
definition you know you have people over
your house you're going to clean up the
house the 21 world leaders you got tens
of thousands of people coming from all
uh around the globe uh what an
opportunity to showcase the world's most
extraordinary Place San Francisco yeah
all you San Francisco residents can live
with the crackheads and the gangsters
but chairman she shouldn't have to deal
with that San Francisco can be an
incredible City yes it can be California
can be an amazing State America can be
an amazing
country all of those things are in a
state of decline right now by the choice
of our leaders who could fix them in a
heartbeat if they cared even one tenth
as much about the American people as
they do about the opinion of a foreign
communist dictator I'm Michael nolles
this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers claim
your year of free meat $15 off and free
shipping with my promo code nolles KO
wle at good ranchers.com that is
goodranchers.com promo code nolles canw
Lees today I've been traveling over the
weekend from Friday through Sunday which
means I'm furious because it's been now
five or potentially even six days since
I've eaten good ranchers for dinner and
that is way too long if you ask me
looking forward to that tonight or later
this week also Megan
rapino has just made a novel argument as
to why God does not exist we'll get to
that in just a moment first though
speaking of dictators the
Democrats they've got a new strategy for
taking down Donald Trump well they have
a strategy for taking down the new
strategy is the same as the old strategy
it's the strategy that that they have
been using the entire time to finally
take down Donald Trump and it is to
compare him to a fascist
dictator in honor of our great veterans
on Veterans Day we pledge to you that we
will root out the Communists marxists
fascist and the radical left thugs that
live like Vermin within the confines of
our country that lie and steal and cheat
on elections that threat from outside
forces is far less Sinister dangerous
and Grave than the threat from within
all right let's bring in right now the
Rogers chair of the American presidency
at vanderbelt University historian John
mum uh John um I I I I think uh he
should probably uh give some pay some
royalties uh to melini's Family Trust
because when he starts talking about
rooting out communist Marxist radical
left Vermin uh destroying the country it
is it is he he's L he's lifting it from
melini and other fascists from the
past wow
whoa what an amazing interesting take
I've never heard anything like that
before I Joe scoro he just made me see
Donald Trump in an entirely new light
because you see hold on I don't know if
you caught this Joe Scarboro is calling
Trump a
fascist wow man that must be why they
pay him tens of millions of dollars a
year that's why he makes the big bucks
for really insightful perspicacious
takes like
that the conservative is
fases what what a
stupid level of political discourse we
have in this country that that that's
the height because Joe Scarboro he wears
glasses you know he wears glasses say he
has a necktie and a jacket he's on MSNBC
you know there this is really high level
stuff here
saying conservatives are Fascist it's so
dumb and so what's the response what do
conservatives say to this I think 10 or
15 years ago what conservatives would
have said
is no we're not fascists no no we
actually you don't you just you just
don't understand we support smaller
government and you and then with that
argument that with that what that
rejoiner turned into over time was
actually Democrats when you really think
about it you're the real fascists
because you see you want to wield
government power more than we do so you
you're just totally misunderstanding
this whole situation because I if anyone
I'm not saying anyone's a fascist here
but if anyone's going to be like a
fascist it's you not us and now do you
know what the answer is do you know what
I think at least this is my conservative
answer to Joe Scarboro or any other
Democrat who knows nothing about
political philosophy who knows certainly
nothing about fascism who knows nothing
about the American political order as it
once was and could be again my answer
is
okay whatever bro sure no but you're a
you're a fascist you're just like
musolini okay that's fine I got a little
more hair than musolini I don't know my
jaw is not quite as wide but sure fine
okay why not why
not fascism doesn't mean anything
anymore it it once actually did mean
something and unlike Joe Scarboro or any
Democrat really at all at the national
level I've read the founding documents
of fascism for goodness sakes I my
double major was in Italian literature
there there isn't that much to read if
you study Italian literature it's Dante
petrarch bacho and the fascists the
fascist poets and the theorists and the
aesthetic philosophers and it's people
like marinetti and aleste de amri and
Giovanni Gentile and musolini and then a
bunch of poets in the 20th century so
yes I've read all the documents I'm not
a fascist I don't agree with the
premises of fascism fascism is much much
more Progressive than anything that I
believe in but sure you're going to call
me that all right
whatever do does Scarboro think it's
going to work this time is this real the
Democrats have exhausted everything else
they accused Trump of being a Russian
stooge a KGB Sleeper Cell they accused
Trump of then colluding with the
ukrainians who were at war with the
Russians but he colluded with both I
guess they accused Donald Trump of
injecting people with bleach they
accused Donald Trump of raping a woman
in a Bergdorf Goodman 30 years ago they
accused Donald Trump of donating too
much money to his own campaign they
accused Donald Trump of of calling the
secretary of state of Georgia while he
was President of the United States
totally fine they accused Donald Trump
of having classified documents that he
had every right to have when he was
president of the United States they and
what now they're back now they've gone
full circle they're back to her dur
you're a fascist okay I guess Donald
Trump's getting elected then if that's
the best they've got I
guess unless maybe it'll work this time
maybe it'll work this time guys so
they've got another
strategy Beyond The Joe Scarboro
strategy of of repeating talking points
that were stale and ridiculous in 2011
and the other strategy is they're going
to try to get everyone close to Donald
Trump his lawyers his AIDS his
staffers they're going to try to get
them to say all sorts of terrible things
about Trump one such person they're
doing that to is my friend Jenna Ellis
so you know Jenna Ellis was the lawyer
for Donald Trump she has decided to work
with the prosecution she took a plea
deal and it was very sad because it was
obviously just some stalinesque show
trial where they made her cry on camera
and it was sad not just for Jenna it was
sad for the state of the country that we
now do this sort of thing that we once
saw primarily in the Soviet Union I know
a lot of people are very angry with
Jenna for working with the
prosecution I can't even imagine the
kind of pressure she was under I suspect
a lot of the people attacking Jennifer
doing that would have done exactly the
same thing in her shoes but regardless
put that aside for a second here is the
vide tape that they've got now the walls
are closing in they've got Trump now
Jenna explain
here's the Smoking Gun of Donald Trump
the
insurrectionist at the time uh period
where that we're going to start to
discuss what was uh Dan gabino's role at
the time I believe his title was social
media director for the White House it
became Deputy Chief of Staff um at the
time that the conversation in question
took place okay and when was that the
conversation was around December 19th of
2020 uh at the White House Christmas
party and I emphasized him I thought
that the um the the claims and the
ability to challenge uh the election
results was essentially over because he
said um to me in a kind of excited tone
well we don't care and we're not going
to leave and I said what do you mean and
he said well the boss meaning president
Trump and everyone understood the boss
um that's what we all called him um he
said the boss uh is not going to leave
under any circumstances we are just
going to stay in power and I said well
doesn't quite work that way you realize
and he said we don't
care okay so all of the liberal stations
are playing this clip now obviously it
was leaked this is an interview between
a prosecutor and the former lawyer for
Trump put aside for a moment whatever
feelings you have about Jenna
cooperating with the prosecution put
that aside for a moment and just ask
yourself what does this
matter even let's say that
Jenna's testimony to the prosecutor had
been 10 or 20 times more titillating
than that was I talked to a guy at the
White House Christmas party and the guy
at the White House Christmas party told
me that they were not going to leave
office see there it is there's proof
that Donald Trump is an insurrectionist
who was going to stop the peaceful
transfer of power who was going to
overthrow our elections who was going to
shred the
Constitution what does any of that
matter when the fact is he did leave the
white house and he didn't stay an extra
week he didn't ask for a late
checkout he left the White House when
Joe Biden was sworn
in so even if everything Jen is saying
there is true even if the prosecution
thinks they've got a big Smoking Gun
what what actual legal significance does
it have if Donald Trump didn't do any of
those things that they're accusing him
of wanting to have done
it it it's almost as bad as the Joe
Scarboro line because you're just you're
left scratching your head and you're
saying is this the best they've got and
it is the best they've got everyone's
going to keep waiting for some another
shoe to drop wow here's another private
conversation between some Trump staffer
and some other Trump staffer oh no
here's there here's an email that went
around to the Trump campaign or Super
PAC or something
but the fact is
nothing that Donald Trump did just
before January 6th just after January
6th at during the transition period
challenging the election which was
obviously
rigged nothing that he did was all that
out of the ordinary in American politics
th those of us who live through Bush
Vore know that challenging elections is
not particularly out of the ordinary at
least when it's Democrats who were doing
it nothing he did was illegal or
unconstitutional as far as I can tell
and certainly nothing he did would
justify this unprecedented Banana
Republic like maneuver of trying to
throw the former president and current
leader of the political opposition into
prison it's all just a a sideshow what
the prosecutors are doing here by trying
to dribble out all this testimony from
the Trump Confidant by Prosecuting them
in the first place is essentially no
different from Joe Garbo's attack on
Trump which is just heard there he's a
fascist believe me what does it amount
to nothing absolutely nothing at all
they might they might still get him in
the sense
that I guess they could have impeached
him for Russia collusion or Ukraine
collusion or this collusion or that
collusion
but it it would not have been Justified
at all they've never they've been trying
for seven eight years now they've never
proved their case against the man it's
all out of balance our political order
and when you want to restore balance to
your body you you might consider
consider restoring balance to Nature
that's why you got to check out balance
of nature right now go to balanceof
nature.com use promo code nolles kws
living a healthy lifestyle it's not easy
especially when you're always on the go
you need simple manageable routines to
make sure you're getting the proper
nutrition every day which is why I'm a
huge fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day balance of nature uses an
advanced cold vacuum process that
encapsulates fruits and vegetables into
Whole Food supplements without
sacrificing their natural antioxidants
the capsules are completely void of
additives fillers extracts synthetics
pesticides or added sugar the only thing
in balance of Nature's fruit and veggie
capsules are well fruits and veggies
there's never been an easier way to make
sure you're getting your daily dose of
fruits and vegetables go to balance of
nature.com use promo code n canw for 35%
off your first order as a preferred
customer that's balanceof nature.com
promocodes kwes for 35% off
your first preferred order balance
of.com speaking of
transitions a
[Music]
psycho now speaking of violence against
innocent people you have got to go check
out pre-born right now go to pre-born
docomo's little things can make a big
difference a little note a little smile
a precious little baby when you sponsor
an ultrasound at pre-born your gift no
matter how small makes a big difference
in a big way who will this little baby
become what life will this baby live
about the mother who was spared from
unspeakable sorrow because of you a
small donation of just 28 bucks gives a
mother the opportunity to meet her child
through ultrasound which could help
double a baby's chance at life all
you've got to do is take a few minutes
today to make a life-saving donation
pre-born will take it from there
pre-born network of clinics rescues 200
tiny babies every day simple as that
they also fund raise separately for
their administrative costs so every
dollar you give is going directly
towards saving babies and they get
results 200 every day it's very simple
the mother gets an ultrasound doubles
the chance that she will not have an
abortion this is a very simple effective
way to do your part to help save
innocent little babies get involveed
today by dialing pound 250 say keyword
baby or go to pre-born docomo klees that
is pre-worn
docomo Black Friday is coming and the
dailywire has the best deals around
starting Monday get 50% 550% off a
dailywire plus membership and all kinds
of amazing deals on Jeremy's razor
products and tons of merch from our
dailywire shop there is something for
everyone go to dailywire.com blackf
Friday and get the full guide to all of
our Black Friday deals do not forget to
tune in all next week find out more
remember these deals start on Monday run
through Cyber Monday but we will sell
out fast do not wait get the guide and
and start checking off your holiday
shopping list one more time
dailywire.com blackf Friday for the best
deals of the Year speaking of attacks on
people really really sad story awful
story just came out a 17-year-old boy
Jonathan Lewis was just beaten to death
by a mob of 15 people just a few blocks
away from his high
school after this kid stood up for a
smaller friend of his who was getting
beaten up and this mob had put the kid
into a trash can so he stood up to them
and then the beat him to death and you
haven't heard about this story probably
if you've heard about it you've heard
about it on this show and maybe a few
other conservative outlets and the
reason that you haven't heard about this
story is because the victim was white he
was a white boy 17 years old and all of
the perpetrators are
black and that doesn't fit the narrative
you're not you're not allowed to even
observe that happening so it's been
mostly out of the mainstream Media Local
News covered it you know you can see uh
CBS Channel 8 covered it live local now
some conservative Outlets have covered
it because it's so egregious it's such a
hor and there's video of it it's just
totally horrific but also because it
tells you something about the media that
we here at the daily wire have been
observing for a long
time the reason I mention this is is not
to State something about the the real
state of violence in the country or the
real state of race relation even or
anything like that the reason I state it
is because it proves that all news is
fake we at the daily wire have said that
for a long time maybe it was Drew who
first put it in those words but this was
years ago when the term fake news was
popularized by the left to attack us
specifically actually it was it was a
term that was promoted by the left to
attack conservative news broadly and the
daily wire specifically we were on their
list of fake news sites and then Donald
Trump brilliantly took the term
reappropriated the term and used it to
attack CNN and NBC and the New York
Times And The Washington Post and that's
stuck that's now the way that we use
fake
news but when we say that the news is
fake we don't just mean that one story
is not real you know Trump's collusion
story that that didn't really
happen when we say the news is fake we
mean the whole news and the reason it's
fake is because they only show you
things that butus their predetermined
narrative which they arrived at before
examining any facts they just arrived at
it based on their own false ideology and
then anything that fits in with that
narrative they will include in the news
so they have this ideology that says
that white people are evil and we're
terrible oppressors and black people are
innocent victims and so any story that
in any way can be shoehorned into
fitting that narrative the George Floyd
story The bana Taylor Banna Taylor is
working with a major Criminal
and somehow that was a story of white
man attacking an innocent black woman so
but they shoehorned it in anyway or any
any story like this Kyle writtenhouse
they called him a white supremacist who
was slaughtering innocent black people
at a BLM
Riot little little did they even know
that the people that Kyle writtenhouse
shot were all white and some of them
were pedophiles convicted pedophiles no
no no I didn't okay darn we got to move
on from there then
but the stories that go into the news
are only the ones that back up their
narrative so as a consequence of that
all the news is fake you can't really
believe any of it because the little
pieces of information sometimes true
sometimes false are are only there and
only presented to you in order to
promote a narrative that has really no
connection to the facts and that is
ultimately
false to begin with a really really sad
story awful we should obviously pray for
for the young man and for his whole
family and take it as a lesson to just
just tune out the news as many of us
have done now speaking of fake news
here's a story here's a real fake news
story this is one I truly know nothing
about I know nothing about really any of
the people involved one person I know a
tiny bit about here's a story Chris
Appleton files for a divorce from Lucas
G age after 6 months of marriage I said
well Chris can be a woman's name but in
this case I believe Chris is not a
woman's name Chris is a man's name so
you're saying th a man has filed for
divorce from another man after six
months of
marriage and then here's the
kicker uh Kim Kardashian one of
Appleton's clients officiated the
ceremony and Shia Twain
performed
so
none of that happened none of like
something happened that involved these
people but none of the things that this
news article says happened actually
happened Chris Appleton did not file for
divorce from Lucas Gage because two men
cannot divorce one another because two
men cannot marry one another because
marriage intrinsically involves sexual
difference and the complimentarity of
the Sexes and Kim Kardashian did not
officiate that wedding one because it
was not a wedding and two because Kim
Kardashian is not a priest because women
can't be priests and because Kim
Kardashian even if she were pretending
to be a priest in this case wasn't even
pretending to have some religious role
and marriage has always been both a
religious and
civil
institution but other than that the
story makes perfect sense right I say
none of this with any antipathy
whatsoever toward Chris Appleton or
Lucas Gage neither of whom I've ever
heard of I say this actually with no
antipathy toward Kim Kardashian even and
I say this certainly with no antipathy
toward guys who are a little bit light
in the loafers you know I'm from New
York I lived in La I went to the gayest
university in the United States a
disproportionate number of my friends
have unusual and eccentric sexual
desires and behaviors I don't I love
them very dearly I have no antipathy or
hatred for anybody but this just isn't
real none of this is real it's all
fake the reason I mention the story is
one because we're talking about the fake
news but two because it shows you
how far how far we have to go to restore
even the basic elements of a stable
flourishing Society it is not possible
to have a stable flourishing Society if
your fundamental political
institution is wacky is ambiguous is
controversial for all of human history
everywhere on planet Earth the
fundamental political unit is the family
and the the fundamental component of the
family is a marriage and the the
fundamental aspect of the marriage is
the complimentarity of the Sexes this is
the fundamental distinction in
mankind and if we deny that things are
not going to work out very
well you might say well I I don't want
men and women to be different well okay
sorry I'm sorry that you feel that way
but they are well I don't I don't want
the marriage to be a fundamental unit of
society okay well man's a coupling
creature and the political animal and
that's just the way it is I'm sorry you
feel that way maybe you'd prefer a
thruple or a quadruple maybe you'd
rather we all live in some deracinated
desexed utopian Vision that you might
have where where those things don't
matter but that's not that's not the way
it is to quote the great baseball player
Oscar gamble some people don't think
it'd be like it is but it do but it
do and so I I know that there are a lot
of conservatives who think well if if
only we just there are even some
sensible liberals especially sensible
liberals who will say we just got to cut
this woke stuff we just gota come on man
[Music]
you're we we are so far removed from a
normal stable flourishing society
that what what would be required to get
back to any semblance of of good living
is going to require far greater
confidence and far greater Clarity
because Clarity is Charity baby that's
what I
think now speaking of disordered views
of men and women let's turn our
attention to women's soccer where Megan
rapino you know Megan rapino she's a
left-wing activist who I think uh
coincidentally also plays soccer Megan
rapino has a novel
argument as to why God does not exist
and the argument comes because in Megan
Rino's final match of her
career uh she was injured and so she
didn't get to finish her match and she
said this was was greatly unfair and
proof that God does not
exist before we get to Megan's argument
I have to
ask how many times is this woman going
to retire from soccer because I I saw
this headline and I said wait a second
Megan rapino is still playing soccer I
distinctly remember months ago reading
that Megan rapino had played her last
match and something went wrong in that
too and she was whining about that she
was complaining about whatever happened
in that game and then I said okay well
she's whining and complaining and she's
a very difficult woman to listen to but
hey at least she is done with soccer and
I don't need to read about her anymore
and her Antics and her anti-American
activism but then months later I have to
read about Megan rapino again so then I
looked and I said oh this was her last
game too but I I turns out I was right
because I looked up this is the same
news source this is ABC News September
25th what happened at Megan Rino's final
Us wnt game Team USA scored a victory
against South Africa in Rino's final
game September 25th Rino's final game
then ABC News November 11th Megan rapino
exits nwsl Championship with injury in
final game how many final games is this
woman going to have can can this be the
final final please if we if we had
enough Megan rapino I certainly
have right after she makes her argument
as to why God does not exist which we
will get to right after I tell you about
beam Organics right now go to shop Beam
Beam
m.com are you struggling to sleep at
night did you know that poor sleep can
cause weight gain mood issues poor
mental health and lowered productivity
sleep is the foundation of our mental
and physical health and performance you
must have a consistent nighttime routine
to function function at your best if
you're struggling with sleep you got to
go check out Beam Beam is designed to
help you fall asleep stay asleep and
wake up refreshed beam's dream powder
not only Rhymes it contains a powerful
allnatural blend of ingredients
including magnesium L theanine they sent
some dream powder down to the studio for
our team to try apparently the team
stole all of it already because I
haven't even gotten to have a nice extra
heaping helping of beam and beam is
helping people fall asleep stay asleep
unlike regular sleeping pills that will
make you wake up feeling groggy beam
will help you wake up ready to go just
mix beam dream into hot water or milk
yum stir and froth and enjoy before
bedtime and today our listeners can get
a special discount on beam's delicious
dream powder they're bestselling hot
cocoa for sleep with no added sugar they
have flavors like cinnamon cocoa
chocolate peanut butter better sleep has
never tasted better go check out their
bestselling dream powder take advantage
of their biggest sale of the Year get up
to 50% 5% off for a limited time beam
right now shop beam.com kwes your
discount is auto applied at checkout no
code is necessary bam that's the name of
the company go to shop
beam.com for up to 50% off my favorite
comment yesterday is from Crazy Wolf
5150 who says the fact that they waited
to clean up that City San Francisco
right before the Chinese dictator was
about to visit shows you who they're
truly loyal to that's you're you make a
good point you make a good point Gavin
Newsome it's sometimes happens to people
even in their own families they're
really mean to their family members but
they're really nice to Outsiders but you
know charity begins at home folks and
Gavin nome's charity needs to begin at
in San Francisco all right not in
Beijing at long last here is Megan
Rino's argument as to why God does not
exist this is a long one although I'm
I'm going to get the Aaron Rogers
treatment whatever that is um so to be
calling him or whoever did his surgery
because we need to speed this up but
yeah I thought about a little bit I mean
you know I'm not a religious person or
anything and if there was a god like
this is proof that there isn't this is
up um so yeah it just it's just guys six
minutes in eat my KES I mean
what so the argument let's take it she's
obviously being tongue in here but the
argument is an argument that a lot of
Reddit tier atheists make which is
because a bad thing happened to me
that's proof that God does not exist but
you know this is an old problem that
people have been grappling with for uh
ever and it's theodicy it's the problem
of pain and suffering given a God who is
om omnipotent and Omni benevolent and
omnipresent uh some people I think have
pointed to this this as a great example
a great counterargument to the argument
that Megan Rino thinks she's making the
fact that this woman who in her public
life is quite odious uh was not able to
play what I hope is her final game of
soccer uh might not be seen as proof
that God does not exist some would
actually come to quite the opposite
conclusion here but even if one did
not uh it Bears repeating because
because one can understand it
intellectually but when you actually do
rip your Achilles when you're playing
your last game and it's really
meaningful to you you act you actually
will cry out to God very often and be
very angry with God even faithful people
will do that very often so I have a bit
of sympathy for Megan rapino here but
when you think about it
intellectually and you remove yourself
from the immediate pain of it uh you can
see it all quite clearly suffering is
not a proof against God's existence
because suffering has no moral moral
quality in and of itself it is the
reaction to suffering that has a moral
quality and the reaction to suffering
can be one that is degrading and is uh
vicious or the reaction to suffering can
be edifying and sanctifying and you can
come out strong whatever doesn't kill
you makes you stronger would be a
shallow way to put it and that's the
case and why is there sin and death in
the world because man has Free Will and
abused his free will to rebel against
God and as a consequence of that sin and
death pervade the world and and there
are Eternal consequences for sin but
there are also temporal effects of sin
so when you commit a sin you can you can
go and as it says in the gospel you can
go and confess your sins and the uh
successors to the apostles can forgive
your sins they can give you
Absolution uh and and that takes care of
the Eternal consequences of sin but
there's still temporal consequences of
sin if you go out and steal a candy bar
and then you go and you say I'm sorry I
apologize you know God forgive me please
and then you receive Absolution from God
well the shop owner is still out a candy
bar he's still out a couple of bucks
there's still a temporal effect of that
and uh so sin and death pervade the
world beautifully uh described by John
Milton in Paradise Lost and but the the
happy ending to that is that uh there's
a solution and there's actually
Redemption that comes through suffering
and ultimately through the suffering of
the perfect victim who's totally
innocent and that's why we say on Easter
oh happy fault that won for us so great
So Glorious Redeemer so probably
probably a more in-depth answer than
Megan rapino was looking for but since
that is her final game of soccer I hope
I figured it would be good opportunity
to give it to her speaking of
feminism I've got a terrible news story
for me I guess it's good for the culture
but it's really bad for me and the story
is this there's some new feminist Marvel
movie out based on Captain Marvel which
I labored through for the daily wire
some years ago whenever it came out it's
with some woman Brie Larson is the
actress in it and it was really just
Dreadful and then they made a sequel to
it called the Marvels which just came
out and it appears to be the lowest
opening weekend in Marvel franchise
history it pulled in 47 million bucks so
this is good for the culture because I
don't I don't like the Marvel movies
generally I really don't like feminist
movies uh un unless they're at least uh
provocative or interesting or show me
something from a new angle and it's not
just Joe Scarboro tier you know my
enemies are fascists kind of stuff but
but that rarely happens in in any movie
especially feminist movies so I don't
like that and then you combine the the
two so you've got this really shallow
formulaic movie that just inserts a
bunch of woke girl boss uh catchphrases
into it and it's just absolutely
unbearable so it's good that the people
rejected that but it's really bad
because it means I'm going to have to
watch this movie now because the sadist
in the control room Mr Davies is going
to make me do it so that I can give a
review if if this movie is a a news
story if people either because it's so
popular because it's so unpopular I
guess I'm gonna have to watch this
thing even though I know I know how bad
it's going to be because I saw the first
one when this movie was announced it was
lauded for having three female leads
that is your first sign it's just that
South Park clip Kathleen Kennedy make it
more lame add four female leads and no
one wants to see that because
what people want to see when they go see
a hero movie whether it's an old western
with John Wayne or whether it's a new
movie with Chris Pratt they want to see
a man do manly things Feats of Strength
because men are physically stronger than
women and men are more publicly oriented
than women women tend to be more
nurturing and oriented toward the
private life and so the men want to go
see a man go out there and conquer the
world and they want to see a woman be
saved because men want to save a damsel
in distress because Men actually love
don't hate women they love women and
what do the the women want to see they
want to see the same thing that's the
big
secret no women are looking up to bre no
little girls are looking up to Brie
Larson or any of these ridiculous women
these feminist women characters because
those feminist women characters are
divorced from reality and everything
about them is divorced from reality
their physical abilities most obviously
women can't beat men in fights pretty
much ever under any circumstances it
just can't happen we TW that story
yesterday 15-year-old High School boys
soccer beats professional women's soccer
like every time so that is the most
obvious but furthermore the notion that
women don't desire men that's just false
that's not true a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle like the
feminists say it's just not true none of
this stuff is true and so it doesn't
resonate for the men it doesn't resonate
for the women doesn't resonate for
anybody according to the Box Office
return and I bet it's not going to
resonate for me when freaking Ben Davies
makes me watch it now today this Tuesday
speaking of confusing men and women so
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code NES KW so check out for two
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans